salut c'est jimmy et je suis ravi de
vous retrouver pour notre rendez-vous
voyages quotidiens sur la première
aujourd'hui direction l'asie je vous
emmène à bali retrouver un jeune
martiniquais s'appelle canal seine nord
il a quitté son île il ya quelques
années pour vivre son rêve et ça se
passe plutôt bien pour lui
[Musique]
ça me kane sall est unique et ben nous
ça va on commença à des confiné donc on
espère que ça ira de mieux en mieux
et toi à bali comment ça se passe paris
n'a pas été street
on a eu beaucoup de réflexions notamment
au niveau des commerces
il faut des molles au niveau des plages
notamment sont fermés et toutes les
activités touristiques sont cernés mais
on n'est pas considéré nous on est quand
même dix coups à la sortie des bien sûr
avec toutes les mesures de protection
ciel dans le masque obligatoire
on fait tout notre possible pour
protéger les autres parce que d'après ce
qu'on a compris qu étant jeunes les
moins impactées voilà notre responsable
ou cc voilà de protéger des puissances
ok je sais pas si tu le sais mais quand
on dit ben ali tout de suite nous on
pense un voyage dépaysement vacances
lieu magnifique
toi tu lis vie c'est comment ben ali
c'est comme ça comme on imagine un mais
les photos des personnes du monde entier
cat et voilà ce genre de petites images
parce que baby voilà ça tous les gens du
monde entier
il ya des gens c'est pas parce que
effectivement comme déjà dit les plages
la montée des petites îles à côté tu
sais que ben ali c'est juste une petite
partie en asie à quelques années avant
ben ali jointe et à singapour c'est ça
voilà j'étais assez gameboy advance et
gap où j'étais en chine
donc j'ai commencé par le nord de l'asie
et je suis descendu dans la soupe est ce
parce que voilà que tu es plus proche de
la culture mandingue et c'est promis
c'est chaud voilà les hommes sont très
belles
maquillage alors oui parce qu'on n'a pas
dit à la base de maquilleurs
internationale tu m'as kid et des stars
du très connu d'ailleurs dans le milieu
du make up comme on dit comme étant un
des meilleurs artistes reconnus en tout
cas dans ton domaine
et du coup c'est d'ailleurs je vois sur
les étagères derrière j'imagine que
c'est des produits de maquillage qui a
derrière
comment ça t'es venue cette passion du
maquillage ça a commencé comme en voilà
l apprenti est d'abord en matinée
parce que ses remarques cyniques logique
d'accord vous êtes né dans ce bébé
justement cet univers de beauté
et voilà vous pouvez également décider
voilà il ya des étapes pour arriver à
passer dans la france fait mes études
ensuite la chine m'a permis d'avoir
s'est pas d'abord l'indélébile disent
que quand vous parlez chinois ça parle
ça vous au roi des comptes dans le monde
entier vous pouvez parler d'un milliard
de personnes
après voilà voilà une opportunité aussi
une obligation de 41,7 des facultés
mais après voilà abusé fit valoir
voilà tu te sens tu peux développer ta
carrière est bien aussi quand tu es bon
matin du 13 et tout ce que tu viens de
nous dire là attends-toi avoir plein
dans ciels débarqué à bali moi je te
préviens voilà c'est pas mon métier
l'organisme plein de choses tu vois
c'est des photoshoots ou des bateaux des
enfants les hélicoptères pour faire des
toiles tendues
voilà hockey des superbes villas avec
piscine donc vous voulez faire un petit
tour écoutez nous faire rêver tu nous
fait rêver
qu'est-ce qu'il faut absolument voir si
on vient à bali est ce qu'on va tout
faire bien évidemment j'imagine mais qu
est-ce qu il ya des choses des lieux
incontournables avoir à manger à
connaître voyage culinaire
ça c'est bon ça va passer soumis à tous
les deux autour du cochon par exemple
mais qu'ils aiment aussi très épicé et
subrip après le voyage culturel
religieusement parce que c'est quand tu
sais déjà goûté cliff dubois garde un
espèce de noël mais avec des plages de
sable même si la journée si on fait dans
ta vie tu as qu'une envie c'est pour
déclencher puis à les suivre au mieux 4
tonnes oui c'est juste que c'est
différent dans une recherche des bons
dissipation des faits bon écoute on
était content en tout cas de prendre de
tes nouvelles de savoir que ça va bien
de ton côté puis de découvrir un petit
peu ben ali à travers toi en tout cas ça
nous a donné énormément envie de venir
découvrir on viendrait que d'autres
planches de surf histoire de vérifier si
c'est aussi bien qu'à tartane merci en
tout cas keynes était vraiment à plaisir
c'est moi qui te remercie du nil ici je
fais passer bonjour tu vois tout de la
femme mais elle s'adresse à tous à la
salle françois tu c'est une journée yes
week end un bon courage du côté de ben
ali et on se revoit sûrement très
bientôt en martinique merci à toi en
tout cas c'était canal seine nord comme
quoi les martiniquais sont partout et on
peut vivre ses rêves même à des milliers
de kilomètres de son île
à condition de s'en donner les moyens
voilà c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on
se retrouve très vite avec un nouveau
martinique est à découvrir quelque part
dans le monde a très vite sur la
première
[Musique]